[Música]
hola buenas noches como ésta escuchar tu
voz se rompe dios
bueno
y hoy al no ver en el vídeo
[Música]
la idea de pueblo del sol es crear una
nueva realidad donde las personas
comenzando por las comunidades indígenas
podamos vivir de otra manera rodeadas de
amor prosperidad abundancia e
integración un contexto donde tengamos
la posibilidad de manifestarnos como
somos aprovechar nuestros dones
naturales y disfrutar de los regalos de
nuestra madre tierra
en el transcurso de aproximadamente dos
años ya tenemos caminos al pinter y a
casa energía solar comunicación dos
campamentos y varias hectáreas de café
orgánico sembradas hemos logrado tener
nuestros propios viveros varias colmenas
de abejas ya tuvimos algunas cosechas de
miel y nuestra primera cosecha de café
el último cierre de agro
todo está tomando forma todo está
tomando mucho color estamos recibiendo
una respuesta mucho más rápida de lo que
esperábamos se están formando grupos y
amistades increíbles ya todos enfocados
en construir este pueblo juntos este fin
de año celebraremos nuestro segundo
aniversario con más de 150 participantes
de trabajadores
la parte más difícil que fue arrancar
conocernos formar equipos y demás ya
pasó ya somos una familia de más de 50
personas que estamos disfrutando y
viviendo la realidad de que esto ya está
sucediendo
muy pronto vamos a construir las
primeras viviendas con técnicas de
bioconstrucción y materiales que
provienen de este mismo lugar
estas casas serán habitadas por los
mismos trabajadores que hoy viven en los
campamentos ya tenemos en que 15 y 20
familias con sus niños que si dios
quiere este año comenzarán a habitar la
tierra también estamos aplicando la
ciencia de bio geometría en la finca
estamos muy contentos y disfrutando de
nuestros arroyos cascadas nuestra agua
nuestra selva hermosa con estos primeros
pobladores comenzaremos una guardería ya
terminamos de construir la primera fase
de la escuelita y tendremos los primeros
alumnos de la escuela de pueblo del sol
con una nueva metodología que se está
usando ya en italia india y otros países
donde aprenderemos principalmente a
descubrir quién soy yo
ya comenzamos con el centro de arte
estamos dando clases de joyería tenemos
un cineclub y muy pronto comenzaremos
con clases de yoga meditación y mucho
más
también estamos diseñando un sistema
financiero interno para que las personas
tengan acceso a créditos justos donde
realmente puedan usarlos para sus
intereses y desarrollar sus propios
proyectos o sueños
mi deseo es que en unos años podamos
tener un modelo nuevo de pueblo que
podrá ser difundido por el mundo y así
poder crear más pueblos del sol en la
tierra para así contribuir con el
florecimiento de una nueva humanidad
bueno anticipo que me emociono fue el
tiempo del momento que me voy en
silencio respiro y vuelvo
bueno buenas noches
soy ezequiel y
hoy quería contarles un poquito cómo fue
el proceso en resumen como llegué a
estar realizando mi sueño de pueblo del
sol
toda la niñez muy bonita por un lado de
lo bastante complicada por otro y pienso
que eso fue lo que me llevó a el niño
ser muy explorador poco rebelde no
siempre buscando maneras de divertirme
hacer mis travesuras y todo el tiempo
buscando trabaja de viajar mucho
bueno estudié orientándome las ciencias
económicas no porque me imaginarán pero
por cuestiones económicas historias
familiares decidí que si conocía cómo se
manejaban los números en algún momento
de mi vida iba a poder construir una
estabilidad económica
y comencé a trabajar bastante joven para
pagar mis estudios
entre estudios y trabajos años sabáticos
viajaba mochila va pues viaje por los
cinco continentes viví en cuatro países
tuve que enfrentar las diferentes
culturas diferentes idiomas a diferentes
todo era volver a empezar permanente que
siento que es fue gran parte de lo que
me dé
empezó a dejar animarme ya no tenerle
miedo a los cambios
siempre me recuerdo saltando de un lado
para el otro difícilmente pasaba más de
un año en un lugar o en un trabajo
y estaba buscando y buscando pero nunca
sabía bien que pero yo buscaba
y una de mis metas era la meta económica
y en el proceso que bastante joven tuvo
un hijo que me impulsó responsabilizarme
bastante y a impulsar me más en
conseguir
que en gran parte de mi vida fueron
solamente económicos con un sueño
después de hacer algo no sabía bien qué
pero necesitaba encontrar esa paz
trabajé mucho empezé varias veces en
empresas trabajé sólo él fue más o menos
bien más o menos mal muy mal no tuve que
volver a empezar de cero varias veces
razones de la vida me terminarán
trayendo a méxico que viene literalmente
por seis meses y ya llevo
como 18 años hasta soy mexicano
y bueno poco a poco me fui acercando a
este objetivo económico
y en ese mismo proceso inclusive antes
de llegar siempre seguía faltando
constantemente había algo que no me
llenaba y que por más logros o cosas que
tenía pues siempre faltaba algo
por razones de la sagra y de la vida y
quizás también por esa larga búsqueda
si no me enfrente empezar a incursionar
en mi espiritualidad
entonces de repente era algo que no
tenía ni contemplado entonces pues
empecé a tomar un poquito más de tiempo
para conocerle
algo que no había hecho nunca tenía
tiempo siempre vivía corriendo para
todos lados tiempo de conocer ni sabía
lo que era es una de nueve dichos
conociste
entonces en el paralelo de mi trabajo de
mi vida cotidiana del estrés de la
ciudad todo el tiempo estaba buscando
retomar mis viajes
en este proceso nuevas prácticas nuevas
tradiciones probé un poquito de todo
y en uno de estos viajes un día en la
selva amazónica tuve un sueño
inspirado simplemente por estar en
contacto con la naturaleza al 100% sin
nada de tecnología alrededor las
personas indígenas que nos ayudaban una
vida tan simple y tan hermosa los niños
corriendo de los arroyos y yo decían
loco corriendo estrés el bajo con la
hipoteca los intereses las marcas y
quedan
entonces bueno desde ese viaje
y
empecé a ver
empezaré un mundo nuevo
bueno gracias por varias etapas
trabajando o viajando preguntándome
cosas
en estas
de las cosas más importantes que hice
fue
empezar a preguntarme qué pasa con mi
familia no me había alejado mucho
entonces
las cosas más importantes y que les
aconsejo a todos que tome un tiempo
para
[Aplausos]
en la casa y sentarme con mi madre con
mi padre con mi hermano y decir qué pasa
y restablecer nuestros vínculos no les
quiero hacer el cuento largo pero eso es
una de las cosas que quiero hacer
marcarlo tomarnos un tiempo para estar
con nuestros familiares se solucionan o
no las cosas pero por lo menos para
decirlas porque estructuralmente si nos
dan mucha fuerza
entre idas y vueltas estaba buscando la
manera de aterrizar este plan de
construir un mundo nuevo mientras más me
acercaba nuevos aprendizajes devolvían
alejar y cuando creía que había
entendido y cómo comenzar otra vez me
volví a dejar y entonces quizás
proponerme metas muy altas hasta
inclusive en un momento
y quería ser un país nuevo imagínense se
transformó en una carga tan pesada que
dejó de ser una alegría y pasó a generar
muchas frustraciones entonces por
naturaleza fue dejando mi sueño en un
cajón y esa energía que le dedicaba
tanto a mi sueño se la volvía a dedicar
y para dentro me di cuenta cuánto me
faltaba
volví más prácticas más tradiciones
en este proceso descubrí y otra vez la
meditación que me la habían dicho 50
meses pero podría mandarlo a morado la
meditación después no y me di cuenta
después de muchos años que tenía en mis
manos la herramienta sagrada y principal
que rigen mi vida hoy en día no la
seguirá rigiendo donde me regaló sus
minutos para mí casi todos los días
para estar conmigo buscar esas
respuestas que sé que tengo dentro de
cómo enfrentar el vídeo o cosas que
tengo que resolver ya partir de ahí poco
a poco sin darme cuenta me fui acercando
más a mi corazón
haciendo hincapié
la compañera antes por naturaleza mi
sueño se fue volviendo a acercar y ahí
comencé a dar cuenta que los sueños por
lo general vienen desde el alma por eso
son tan hermosos y son tan puros pero a
veces nos vuelven inalcanzables y me fui
dando cuenta por qué porque a veces
tratamos de alcanzar nuestros sueños
desde esa persona
el personaje este que fuimos creando con
los años de nuestros papás de nuestros
abuelos de la escuela de la pl lo que
nos dijeron que teníamos que ser cómo
hacerlo y de repente estamos tratando de
alcanzar algo tan hermoso pero no
tenemos las herramientas porque nuestro
verdadero yo pues estamos a algún lado
ahora y dibujando entonces hay que
dedicarse mucho a buscar esta verdad y
desde ahí me empecé a hacer preguntas de
tránsito como porque esto hace 20 30
años atrás me pregunté por qué o por qué
no me gusta la religión o no hay cosas
tan tales implicaciones políticas que me
molestaba porque realmente opinaba todo
lo contrario pero si alguna vez le pasó
que se preguntaron por qué tienen
determinadas actitudes que las han
tenido toda su vida y después se dan
cuenta porque ustedes no eran así que su
papá es casi su abuelo las bueno para no
hacer el cuento largo
solito en este autoconocimiento fui
descubriendo enrique acercando a la
verdadera esencia de mi alma
qué es la verdadera esencia del alma
esto mismo que estamos diciendo y
rascarle sacar todas esas cortezas que
fuimos adquiriendo con el tiempo y ir
descubriendo el circuito el palito
amarilla la que está ahí abajo diciendo
hola quiero salir no entonces a medida
que te vas haciendo esas preguntas
y te das el tiempo para responderlas
porque a veces parece que sí
un poquito más porque siempre más
preguntas para hacer
me estoy acercando a mi sueño
y sin darme cuenta de repente estaba en
un puerto escondido en la selva
y dije acá
y empecé a ser pueblo del sol me llevo
todos estos años a entender cómo poner
la primera piedra no tenía un plan
perfecto cómo hacer un pueblo sigo sin
tener lo estamos aprendiendo juntos acá
tenemos algunos representantes del
pueblo y vamos día a día no pero sí supe
cómo empezar y eso es muy importante
cuando queremos empezar algo a veces
démonos el tiempo de cómo va a ser la
primera piedra que es la más importante
y después dejarlo fluir y aprendiendo y
500 nombres en el proceso entonces les
quería compartir algo
i
en este tiempo escribir cosas asumiendo
tomando creencias y creando una visión
que se han transformado y trato de vivir
mi vida acorde a lo que les voy a decir
y tomar las decisiones en las que
tenemos un pueblo del sol como un
estatuto de palabra
entonces debe pedir un segundito que nos
traigamos un poco de lo que ha estado
pasando cerremos los ojos
y vayamos a nuestros lugares especiales
a nuestro paraíso personal un lugar
cómodo donde nos sintamos tranquilos
respiremos profundo
y les pido si pueden seguir lo que voy
diciendo desde el corazón sin emitir
juicios ni nada nomás dejen seguir
llegó el punto para la raza humana donde
todo comenzará a florecer
a brillar sin fronteras los tiempos de
oscuridad están llegando a su fin
inminente
los principios básicos y estructurales
de nuestra civilización vuelven a la luz
donde el respeto la claridad la armonía
la abundancia la prosperidad y como
principal eje desde todos los tiempos el
amor incondicional restablecerá el orden
[Música]
no más línea blas tierra
matanzas hambre contaminación de
intereses vacíos gobernados de negocios
límites que nos llevó al no saber hasta
dónde queremos y acá
que mayor destrucción esencialmente que
vivimos este hermoso andamos por la vida
como santa faz
solo esperando y teniendo el amor
pero gracias a dios
estamos en un despertar colectivo donde
más rápido de lo que podemos imaginar
recuperaremos el paraíso de nuestra
madre tierra para adorarlas cuidarla
respetarla
y entender que de ella viene todo lo que
necesitamos para ser felices por siempre
este es un compromiso que tenemos que
asumir todos desde hoy y para el resto
de los tiempos agradeciendo a nuestros
maestros guías y ángeles arcángeles
maestros ascendidos el habernos cuidado
a pesar de todo el daño que causamos y
pidiendo permiso y protección para
comenzar con la estaca barrera que
estuvimos esperando
que la luz vuelva a reinar en la tierra
así es hecho está por los siglos que
vendrán
el pasado quedó en el pasado no hay que
mirar atrás basta de historias de
mentira desconfianza violencia y
corrupción en nuestra descendencia
perdonemos a quien tengamos que perdonar
olvidemos lo que tengamos que olvidar
reconciliémonos por nuestros hermanos y
hermanas arrepintamos y lo que tengamos
que arrepentirnos desde lo más profundo
de nuestro corazón y perdonemos nos
llevamos el presente y miremos hacia
adelante
así es infinita luz de amor y compasión
de dios que ya está y habita en nosotros
para transformar el entendimiento y
percepción que tenemos de nuestra propia
base para llevarla a su origen donde
toda la presión sobrante
no hay tiempo que perder esto comienza
hoy y permanecerá en el tiempo
lo único que no nos permite ver la luz
somos nosotros mismos porque la luz está
presente en todos lados como la
oscuridad pero nosotros somos luz por
naturaleza y en el momento que seamos
conscientes que sólo nuestra mente
gobernada por el ego lo que ese brillo
tan puro suave poderoso
que en definitiva en la vida misma
daremos un salto cuántico que
grande e identificar
observarla y aprender de ella para así
volverlos más fuertes y menos
que fue la luz a través de nuestras
mentes que fluye a la luz a través de
nuestros corazones que nuestro padre
sonríe en cada rincón de nuestro ser
sagrado que el amor la sabiduría y el
poder sean los instrumentos para
restituir la paz y la unidad entre todos
los seres humanos
y desde este lugar
dentro de unos segunditos más la
atención que cada uno vaya a lo más
profundo de su corazón y vea que
necesita diciendo a ustedes de ustedes
mismos cuál es ese don y ese poder eso
que le gusta ser y le sale naturalmente
con acá lo mejor podrían contribuir en
este proceso de transformación
humanitaria vean esa cualidad observen
la
guarden la y crearla y simplemente el
tengan la activa y sepan que la pueden
usar para lo que sea en su vida
cotidiana siempre
y con todo
mi corazón
le deseo nos deseó un futuro próspero
lleno de alegría y transformación a
nuestro alrededor para el nacimiento de
la nueva humanidad
muchas gracias
[Música]
y podemos abrir los ojos ya
perdona y pues bueno desde las ciencias
económicas las finanzas y el marketing
terminamos en la sierra de oaxaca
los hermanos de las comunidades y
estamos realizando este proyecto hermoso
que
muy pronto podrán visitar vamos a ver
varias áreas de voluntariado que ya les
contaremos y
es lo último que quería decirles de la
que mi objetivo
con esta charla era a ver si podía
lograr inspirarnos un poquitito a ver
hacia adentro y que cumplan sus propios
sueños
[Aplausos]